TALKER.
>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER,
THANKS FOR THE UPDATE.
APPRECIATE IT.
THE IMAGES YOU JUST SAW ARE
EMBARRASSING AND AWKWARD FOR THE
LIARS YOU'VE BEEN WATCHING ON
TELEVISION FOR THE PAST MONTH.
OF THE TO UP AND LECTURING YOU
THAT THE CARAVAN DOESN'T EXIST
AND TELLING YOU THAT EVERYTHING
IS JUST FINE AT THE BORDER.
>> THE PRESIDENT COME ALONG WITH
HIS FAVORITE TV NETWORK,
REPEATING THE DRAMA ON THE
LOOMING SO-CALLED INVASION, AS
THEY PUT IT.
>> THE PROGRAMMING ON THE
CARAVAN WAS PROPAGANDA.
IT WAS POLITICAL, CAMPAIGN
MOTIVATED PROPAGANDA.
>> TRUMP IS LIKE A RACIST PAUL
REVERE, "THE MIGRANTS ARE
COMING."
HE KEEPS CALLING IT AN INVASION.
YES, AN INVASION OF STROLLERS.
>> HE MADE NEWS BY ROCKETING UP
THE CARAVAN, SCARED TALK, ANY
TRUE NUMBERS HE BELIEVES ARE
NEEDED TO MEET THIS ALLEGED
THREAT.
>> Tucker: THE SO-CALLED
INVASION, SO PEOPLE ARE
STREAMING TO THE BORDER, WHAT
WOULD YOU CALL IT?
I DON'T KNOW, YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO CALL IT ANYTHING, ACTUALLY.
THIS IS A RECURRING THEME ON THE
LEFT.
I DON'T BELIEVE YOUR OWN EYES,
YOU ARE TOO DUMB TO TRUST YOUR
OWN SENSES.
LISTEN TO THE SMART KIDS, THEY
KNOW BEST.
THERE IS NO CRISIS ON THE
BORDER.
EVEN AS HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE STREAM INTO THIS COUNTRY
OVER THE YEAR ILLEGALLY, THERE
IS NO ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
CRISIS.
YES, THERE ARE 22 MILLION PEOPLE
LIVING HERE ILLEGALLY, BUT THAT
IS NOT A CRISIS.
IT IS NOT REAL.
THEY WILL TELL YOU THAT ON A
LOOP, ENDLESSLY, UNTIL THE DAY
THEY RETAKE POWER.
AT WHICH POINT THEY WILL SAY THE
CRISIS IS A REAL, IN FACT, IT IS
SO ENORMOUS, WE CAN ONLY SOLVE
IT BY GRANTING BLANKET AMNESTY
TO ALL THE PEOPLE HERE
ILLEGALLY.
22 MILLION, AFTER ALL, WHAT ELSE
CAN WE DO?
THIS IS A METAPHOR, REALLY, FOR
THE LEFT'S ENTIRE PROGRAM, WHICH
IS BUILT ENTIRELY ON DENYING
REALITY, THEY DENY THE REALITY
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION,
TERRORISM, BIOLOGICAL GENDER,
AND WOE TO THE PERSON WHO RAISES
THEIR HAND AND TRIES TO ASSERT
REALITY INTO THE CONVERSATION.
IF THEY DON'T WANT THAT.
WHEN YOU HAVE A PROGRAM BUILT
AND DECEPTION, IT IS NOT
SURPRISING THEY ARE ALSO AGAINST
FREE SPEECH.
YOU CAN'T AFFORD TO HAVE AN
HONEST CONVERSATION.
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE AN HONEST
CONVERSATION.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE SPEAKING TO
RYAN DEAN WRIGHT, FORMER CIA
OFFICER, AND JOINS US ON SITE.
I THINK OUR AND MARK THERE ARE
ARGUMENTS IN FAVOR OF LETTING
THESE PEOPLE IN, THAT IS A
REAL POSITION.
AND MAYBE YOU CAN MAKE THE CASE,
IT IS GOOD FOR AMERICA, GOOD FOR
THE ECONOMY, MAYBE YOU THINK IT
IS BAD AND YOU WANTED ANYWAY.
ALL KINDS OF ARGUMENTS.
WE'LL     BUT WHAT IS NOT AN ARG
WE'LL     BUT WHAT IS NOT AN ARM
WE'LL     BUT WHAT IS NOT AN ARN
WE'LL     BUT WHAT IS NOT AN ART
WE'LL     BUT WHAT IS NOT AN ARI
WE'LL     BUT WHAT IS NOT AN ARS
TELLING ME I AM A RACIST FOR
ACKNOWLEDGING THE REALITY OF
WHAT IS HAPPENING.
AND THAT IS THE POSITION I AM
SEEING ON TELEVISION.
>> YOU ARE CORRECT.
HERE'S WHAT WE SHOULD BE
STARTING WITH THIS CONVERSATION.
THE FACTS.
WHICH WE TYPICALLY DON'T.
SO THE FACTS TELL US THAT
FIRST-GENERATION IMMIGRANTS ARE
A DRAIN ON OUR ECONOMY.
THE SECOND, EVENTUALLY AND THIRD
GENERATION BECOME CONTRIBUTORS.
THAT IS THE FACT.
SECONDARILY.
WE KNOW THAT THE FOLKS COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER, 1,000 TO
2,000 PEOPLE EACH DAY, AGAIN,
HAVING KIDS A YEAR ORATORICAL
YEARS DOWN THE ROAD, TALKING
ABOUT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE, ALL TOLD.
THOSE FOLKS -- INITIALLY,
ANYWAY -- A BIRD INTO OUR
ECONOMY PAIRED WHETHER OR NOT
THEY CAN TRIP YOU DOWN THE ROAD
IS A DIFFERENT CONVERSATION.
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION REGARDLESS OF OUR
POLITICAL AFFILIATION HAD BEEN
TO HAVE A STRONG BORDER, PREVENT
SOME OF THESE FOLKS ARE COMING
ACROSS, AND IF WE DON'T, SHAME
ON US AS A COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: I AGREE WITH THAT.
I DO THINK, AS YOU JUST SAID, IN
MANY WAYS, THIS IS AN ECONOMIC
QUESTION.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW YOU CAN
LOOK AT THE PROJECTIONS FOR WHAT
AUTOMATION IS ABOUT TO DO TO OUR
ECONOMY, ELIMINATING A HUGE
PERCENTAGE OF LOW SKILLED LABOR
IN THIS COUNTRY, AND SAY WE NEED
MORE LOW SKILLED LABOR APPEARED
HOW CAN YOU MAKE THAT ARGUMENT?
>> YOU CAN'T BEAR TO THE TOP TEN
JOBS WE SEE THAT IMMIGRANTS TAK
TAKE, JOBS LESS THAN $20 AN
HOUR.
EVEN THE OBAMA MINISTERS AND
SAID THOSE ARE GOING TO BE
AUTOMATED.
THE ARGUMENT FOR AN INCREASING
NUMBER OF QUALIFIED FOLKS WHO
DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH, DON'T HAVE
A SKILL SET WE NEED FOR THE
ECONOMY, OR FRANKLY, THE ONE
THAT IS ALREADY HERE, THAT IS A
SILLY ARGUMENT.
IT DOESN'T HOLD WATER, SO I
ALWAYS WANT TO BELIEVE THE BEST
ABOUT PEOPLE, THAT THEY HAVE
HONORABLE MOTIVES, AND I THINK
MOST PEOPLE DO, BUT IF YOU CAN'T
EVEN MARTIAL AND ECONOMIC
ARGUMENT IN FAVOR OF YOUR
IMMIGRATION POLICY, I'M LESS --
MAYBE IT IS ONLY ABOUT GETTING
MORE VOTES FOR YOUR PARTY.
>> HOW CYNICAL.
>> Tucker: I DON'T WANT TO BE
CYNICAL.
I JUST DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
RATIONAL.
>> YOU MAY BE CORRECT.
THERE MAY BE PARTS OF THE
PARTY -- MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT
IT, THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS.
JUST THE OTHER DAY -- YESTERDAY,
IN FACT, SENATOR GILLIBRAND FROM
NEW YORK WAS A BUDDY BUDDY WITH
THE GUY WHO WANTS TO REMOVE THE
BORDER BETWEEN THE UNITED STATES
IN MEXICO.
SO THERE IS -- NOT JUST AN
ACTIVIST COMMUNITY, BUT WITHIN
THE LEFT OF THIS NATION, MY OWN
PARTY, I HATE TO SAY -- WHO WANT
OPEN BORDERS.
THAT FEEDS INTO THIS ISSUE, NOT
ONLY DID AND HOW DO WE TAKE CARE
OF THEM, BUT ULTIMATELY, WHERE
THEY TO VOTE FOR?
THERE IS A PLAY THERE THAT I
THINK ONE COULD ARGUE, THIS IS A
POLITICAL PLAY, THIS IS ABOUT
BOATS.
I THINK IT IS THERE TO HAVE THE
CONCERN AND THAT FEAR.
>> Tucker: IF I HEAR ONE MORE
ON CABLE NEWS CRY RACISM WHEN